comment te fais pour tous dans une merde
pareille ils verront bien qu'on m'a
laissé faire matane proulx on m'a laissé
faire
c'est pas suffisant comme preuve j'ai
pas touche à ce [ __ ] de fric il est
dans lesquelles j'ai pas pris un centime
pour moi entré à la société générale
c'est rejoindre les meilleurs parmi les
meilleurs moyens nouveaux traders quart
des vikings l'esprit d'équipé avec une
dernière recommandation
sortez des sentiers battus
une noisette la 5 millions d'euros
imagine qu'on me demande de gagner 5 sur
l'année
chaque trader ces stratégies tout ce que
tu vas gagner en plus grande
trop saint nazaire tenté sur ton truc à
nos sacs à main concrètement la tue les
plans comment je sais pas s'il aboutit
quitte à recruter mais fais ce que je te
demande
comme chaque mois à chercher tes madame
irma
t'as qu'à ta gueule
si on veut réussir leur du boulot il
faut changer ton échelle de valeur en
bas deux cent mille euros c'est beaucoup
vu d'ici que dalle parle de 30 milliards
quand vous me demandez des explications
je voulais tonnes on sait très bien
qu'elles sont pourries des explications
un vrai alors pourquoi mes chefs l'éveil
la tipp qui risquent 15 millions quand
il est limité à 2 du sescam en faisant
virer monter les mines de jeu pile à 5
milliards j'ai joué
sa mort m'a dit je veux punissant
estimez vous que les contrôles ont été
défaillants sale année 2007 on envoyait
74 ans a retranché du camp de jérôme
carrié
comment s'expliquer que personne ne s'en
soit aperçu je m'explique pas